what is the dilemma of magnitude
magnitude means significance substance
is it significant to an audience
um you tend to want to have a good
strong dilemma for your protagonist
but the dilemma can be
weak it may not pass what they call the
so what test
sam cohn the founder of columbia
pictures
used to run his development process like
this he would bring
his writers into a conference room
around a big long table
and he'd put his head down on the end of
the table and go okay what do you got
and the guy would pitch his side he'd be
go so what next blah blah blah so what
and and go around the table and finally
somebody be like ah
yeah that's got something that let's
work on that
so it's that kind of thing it's like it
has to pass the so what test you've
probably seen movies
where you're watching it and it gets
going and you're like
wait is that all this is come on
you know it's like or
they're telling you a story and
you can tell that
they want you to feel x y and z about
your main character but you don't and
you're like
i just don't care that's called trying
to dictate an emotional response
it's like i'm saying you have to feel
this way about this character because i
say so
and you're like i hate this person you
know it's like i don't i'm not invested
in them i did
and and that has a lot to do with like
magnitude because if you are
focusing on the specific aspect of a
good strong dilemma for your protagonist
it really has to be strong it has to be
significant it has to be of substance
to the audience so that they're really
drawn into it
and that goes hand in glove with
universality too because
they say that the deeper you go the more
universal your story becomes
so that you could be writing a story
about
you know a goats herd in ethiopia and if
you've got a really
deep compelling dilemma then a banker in
tokyo could be like
i'm caught in the same thing and a
fisherman in alaska could be like
i'm living that exact same dilemma of
like
honor versus duty or so you know what
it's like if the average person in the
audience
if it hits the average person in the
audience where they live
then they'll connect to it and
because if they don't care about it then
you've got nothing
because it's all about the audience
whatever your
whatever you're building into your story
has to connect to the audience
and get them up on the edge of their
seat and keep them there
so there's a number of different ways in
which you you have to get the audience
sympathy for the protagonist
and maintain it if the protagonist makes
a bad choice
or whatever then the audience can be
like ah
i'm not rooting for that person anymore
i don't like that i'm done like i don't
care anymore
so you have to get it and keep it and
so magnitude is just one aspect of that
you know it's like i was talking about
there the tools create certain
distinctions
and you want to utilize those
distinctions as clearly as possible
because that's where you get the power
of the tools and magnitude of a dilemma
is one of those distinctions what you
don't want to do
is muddy those distinctions every time
they become inconvenient
because then you lose the power of the
tool
how does a writer know they have a good
strong dilemma well
so much of that comes with experience
with the tool and
knowing how to use it fully and properly
you know it it's like you see that
in a doctor where their ability to
diagnose something that's tricky
has a lot to do with their training and
their experience
and their training often creates
instincts in them
where you know that maybe the professor
in medical school
kept saying never forget this you know
you may
never see it in your whole career but
always look for it
and so even if the doctor doesn't even
remember
that consciously part of their brain is
like going did i
check that box and if they actually do
then they're like
wait does it hurt when you sit up in the
morning and they're like yeah
what does that have to do my head hurts
like no no no okay we got to get you
into surgery right away
you know like they're they don't even
know where that came from but they like
their training is built into their
subconscious at a certain level
so there's a you know it depends on your
experience with the tool
and all that
but you know that's a distinction
between
a deeply trained writer and one who is
solidifying their craft you know even as
you're solidifying your craft
that's a key thing to look for is the
strength of your protagonist's dilemma
because it's so central it's part of the
foundation of your story
so that you know
if you're building a skyscraper and
the foundation has been poured
you know you may get an engineer and go
around and
double check to make sure that the
concrete's set up as hard as it was
supposed to so you don't have weak areas
in your foundation or that the
substructure beneath the foundation
isn't
weak or might collapse in a heavy rain
you really want to make sure
that the basic stuff you're going to
build on is really solid
because everything else that comes after
that is impacted if there's a weakness
in the the first principles and the core
things uh
one of my friends is a martial arts
teacher and he said that
by being a martial arts teacher for so
long
he had to keep focusing on first
principles because that's what he was
teaching a lot of times just the most
basic stuff
but he said after a while he realized
that it was making him
a much more substantial martial artist
because
the first principles are what everything
else is built on
and that that solidified his foundation
and i found that that was true too he
said they're first principles for a
reason they're the main
underlying components that everything
else
comes from so for instance
in i taught nonstop for 18 years in
these
small groups there were six people
maximum and each
i was working with each person on their
own script
so like if i explained dilemma
then i would go around the room and i
might start with you and say okay what's
your story idea
and i you know i explained dilemma i
showed how it worked on godfather
tootsie blade runner things like that
and then you tell me your story idea
that you brought and i've never heard it
before
so you may have you know some completely
wacko comedy that i'm like
wait let me get some coffee so i can
sharpen my brain here i have to like
wrap my brain around it and then look at
it i was like okay
is there a dilemma in the story and if
there is
can i i can feel one i can see one half
of it very clearly
i can feel the other half but i can't
put my finger on it and after a while
it's like oh right it's that oh that's
funny
yeah yeah you got a a comedy with a
dilemma that's funny that's what you
want
like that's clever and you may be saying
i didn't know that was in there
i'm like yeah but that that's my skill
with the tool enabled me to find it
and you're like wow yeah that's i love
that i didn't know that i had that in
there i was like well it
it was there you know but i even i have
substantial expertise in this skill it
took me a bit to kind of feel around in
the mud and be like oh that
wow look at that you know so it's like
skill and and familiarity with
it
but in terms of a student knowing if
they have a good strong dilemma
part of it is experience and part of it
is just
rigorous technique trying to use the
tool
explicitly and to utilize all its
distinctions very clearly because they
have
the distinctions are there for a reason
and have great power
and dramatic writing is generally
considered the most elusive of all the
literary disciplines
it's tricky it's slippery it's hard to
pin down
um a script can work
three quarters of the way through and
then fall apart and nobody knows why it
fell apart and nobody can make it work
or
a script can have look great on paper
have all the top people all the money in
the world
and it goes out and loses a hundred
million dollars on its opening weekend
and the same basic story shot for 62 000
in a shoebox and you know with two
actors
goes on to win best picture and you know
make 100 million dollars and they're
like
it's the same story and we had all the
top people and everything
and they look the same on paper but
there's
worked and i don't know why theirs
worked and i don't know why ours didn't
it's it's slippery and so the ability to
use the tools as
rigorously and explicitly as possible
helps you to grab onto this slippery
thing
that like keeps spinning under your
touch and it's like i can't even pin it
down to
use the tool the more you can use those
distinctions in the tool kind of like
dragon talons
where you can grab this slippery marble
and
make it actually stop in place and
really do
like serious surgery on it and like
okay now that may fix it because i had
this wobble and nothing we did made it
work but
i was able to really pin it down to get
down to real specifics with
it and all of a sudden like that part of
it
oh seems to work better and yeah it
helps the whole thing so it's
part of it is just pure technique
and part of it is just
pure intuition with storytelling skills
and
seat of the pants making stuff up and
it's like mud wrestling it's like you're
down in the mud you can't even see half
the stuff and you're like
i can't even get these two to click
together you know it's
it's not easy to make a script work
and and that's why i keep saying you've
got to have huge
chops as a storyteller and you've got to
have serious craft as a dramatist
and you've got to really be able to
synthesize those two together
and the better you get at that the more
your scripts will tend to work
it's about being consistent a number of
writers
have a great first script and it's a big
hit
and they're the toast to the town and
everybody's hiring them
and they can't make their second script
work and they don't know why their first
script work
and they don't know why the second one
isn't working
and you know being able to be consistent
is really important and so
it's a tricky business it's not easy and
you want to really
have big muscles in every department
storytelling craft is a dramatist
character development
all this stuff you gotta really be
hitting on all cylinders to have a
consistent career
you